à partir de minuit samedi les habitants
de la région ile de france vont devoir
respecter un couvre-feu et oui vous
l'avez dit gregory pour quatre semaines
maximum il devra être respecté de 21h à
6h 21h attention c'est l'heure où il
faudra être chez soi en cas de non
respect vous risquez une amende de 135
euros
le président souhaite que le couvre-feu
dure jusqu'à six semaines mais pour
qu'il soit prolongé
il lui faudra un accord du parlement il
y aura cependant des exceptions pour se
rendre ou rentrer du travail aussi en
cas d'urgence
et oui des dérogations sont possibles
pour des raisons de santé comme l'achat
de médicaments dans une pharmacie de
garde ou pour aller à l'hôpital pour des
raisons professionnelles si vous aurez à
vous empêche d'être chez vous à 21h pour
un voyage en train en avion avec billets
à l'appui pour vous rendre auprès d'un
proche dépendant ou pour sortir votre
animal de compagnie il y aura une
attestation à remplir comme lors du
confinement une attestation qui se
trouvera sur les sites du gouvernement
et du ministère de l'intérieur
elle sera effective pendant une heure
hors déplacements professionnels et
pourra être manuscript voilà qu'on se
couvre feu mais ce n'étaient pas les
seules annonces hier du président de la
république s'il n'ya pas de cadre
vraiment légal
le président a fait appel au civisme et
à la responsabilité de tous avec la
règle des six à respecter même dans le
cadre privé lors d'un dîner entre amis
d'un anniversaire ou au restaurant
il ne faudra pas être plus de 6 pour ce
qui est des fêtes les mariages ou les
anniversaires qui devait se faire dans
des lieux publics type salle des fêtes
ces rassemblements sont interdits
le port du masque est aussi recommandé
par tous là aussi dans la sphère privée
le télétravail est recommandé autant que
possible ce sont des mesures qui vont
aussi avoir un impact économique et
social tout à l'heure le gouvernement a
annoncé d'ailleurs qu'il allait
continuer à soutenir les secteurs les
plus impactés aussi les personnes les
plus fragiles et oui le fonds de
solidarité est très large il sera ouvert
aux entreprises de tous les secteurs
dans les zones de couvre feu toutes les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés en
zone de couvre-feu qui ont perdu 50 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires par rapport à
2019 pourront bénéficier d'une aide
allant jusqu'à 1500 euros
pendant toute la durée du couvre-feu
toujours les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés mais du monde de l'hôtellerie
de la restauration de la culture ou
encore du sport en cas de baisse de 50%
du chiffre d'affaires une aide pour
alléger
kadi 1000 euros par mois en ce qui
concerne les prêts garantis par l'état
une demande de report d'un an
supplémentaire auprès de la fédération
française fédération bancaire française
a été faite par le ministre de
l'économie
ils seront ainsi accessibles jusqu'au 30
juin 2021 et il n'a d'exceptionnel sera
versée aux bénéficiaires du rsa et des
apl cela représente 150 euros minimum
par bénéficiaire et 100 euros par enfant
toutes les mesures annoncées par le
président et par le gouvernement seront
adaptés et précisées d'ici samedi
après différentes concertations